[Music]
and welcome back everybody to a special
holiday edition of the careful boys
where today we are taking a look back on
2023 a glorious and memorable year for
JK news and we're going to talk about
what our favorite and most memorable
moments top moments of JK 2023
are HP moments [__] I think recently I
had a lot I had a lot of fun at the uh
pot I think that was really cool I think
we should do that more that was pretty
sweet yeah no that's one of them that's
one I'm just getting the
ball3 was was what the potluck we had
thursdayt 36 hours ago recy bias is is
very real you know I kind of agree with
the like I think when lockdown happened
it was this weird feeling of like we're
going to come in we got to do our shoot
but we're going right back to our
quarantine lives but it wasn't really
quarantine either cuz there everyone was
like kind of doing their own thing and
then like road tripping or whatever but
it was this weird like people got used
to not hanging out regularly yes the
whole world I think was like that yeah
and then I think um most of the world
got back to normal C in 2022 but for me
I was like just opening the shop running
the shop and if I wasn't in Hawaii I'm
just coming here and then like it was
this I feel like I was a little delayed
so then when we started doing social
izing things I was like oh this is sick
and it started with like Halloween when
he had the um the the K I was like this
is my first party since lockdown dude I
haven't been and then like what the
[__] yeah yeah it was crazy it was cool
seeing you at the K's Halloween party
yeah [__] K's Halloween party yeah so
for 2023 that's a great
memory the best JK memory is the just
Halloween party why why was it why was
it the potluck for you it it's not it's
not the main one right but it's like to
get the ball rolling I think because the
fact that I wasn't there no I just felt
like it was cool everything where
Anthony's not around it was just cool to
see all these like like you said earlier
all these random guests all in one spot
and you're like and then it makes you
think back on the year like man we did
have this guest we had this guest we had
[__] Johnny Chang we had Jared we had
all these cash flow doctor you're seeing
all these people on one spot and you're
like that's pretty crazy that we did
shows we spent time with these people
that we probably would have never hung
out with and now they're chill we do
forget how many guests we have yeah cuz
we just see them one at a time and then
it shoots every like two weeks and then
seeing them all there you're like oh
damn we got a [__] ton of guest yeah and
that's not even including like Chappelle
and like Jesus and all these other guys
all the people that are missing today
yeah no for sure and like that was
really cool because you get to see them
all in one spot and you're like hey
that's pretty tight that we got to
interview all these people you know Navy
Seals like [__] Mike and you know do
meet a lot of these guys oh dude that
was a really cool highlight yeah that
was [__] tight yeah hearing her
stories one of my favorite moments was
the [__] um making uh Jason chedy
pick which one of us he would date that
was such a good video dude sometimes I
feel like we pump out so much content
that some of that [__] gets buried and
I'm like [__] I wish more people
actually knew
like some of the you that's why I just
got watch all of them cuz you never know
when it's like we're going to come out
with weird [__] but Jason cheny dating
show was probably one of the funniest
videos for sure for sure that was really
funny just the and the whole like how he
decided randomly to reveal the Anthony
shirt and it was like we didn't know
when that was going to happen yeah
there's there's a couple there's very
few moments where like my jaws
absolutely was going to be there that
day that's the best
part
so organized around
here oh man um I I especially just
building off that especially love even
like Jason Chen's first times coming on
here and then like him and Bart
realizing that they went to the same
Military Academy
crazy like that that at the potluck cuz
I was asking his wife I was like this is
such a unique experience for me have you
met anybody or through Jas that also
went to that school she goes he had no
one it's such a weird like like
Niche like part of people's lives like
of them going would be able to go to
that school you know it's the school for
weird Taiwanese people it's weird yeah
yeah is he
Taiwanese yeah those odds are really
really crazy and it's crazy because it's
actually mainly white people so it's
crazy that there's two Taiwanese kids
that went there how do they even know
about it that's the weird it's like how
did your mom find it there's no internet
there's nothing for my mom it's easy
because it's like you go there's like a
list of schools that you send delinquent
kids to oh so most kids that [__] up
like crazy you just send them to some
boarding military school and just that's
that's where you send them to that was
easy so it was weird that Jason chenny
went straight from Taiwan to there
that's interesting that means he was a
real bad kid huh I don't know it's weird
probably [__] dude well we can't not
talk about this moment that's what I'm
saying be this for me to be this for me
this is the [__] crazy this is the
low crazy I forget about it all the time
man I can't believe we all that sh all
the fans that get it now that's insane
Dude that [__] blows my mind dude why
would people get it get 2 million this
year yeah oh we did that's why we got
this the best thing is before we got it
too Joe's like we already hit 2 million
man and we're like no we didn't go like
what wait we hit 2
million that still blow up that's so
good that's the
best kind of match now like cuz of
fading faded yeah dude 2 million wow you
know we've been like 1.7 1.9 1.8 1.7 1.5
and it just up and down and up and down
and then finally it's like 2 million and
it stays there but you thought it's 2.04
yeah but you thought we already hit
it like 6 months ago I know this is
probably the Highlight for me yeah me
too cuz it's it's so so like I think we
all in here we all like to laugh and we
love bits and stuff M and this is like
how far you going to go yeah how far you
down to go and then now it's a lifelong
commitment to the bit yep and then it's
also a thing where like I didn't know
like we all said we're going to do it
but the day of it's like who's really
going to do it so the Nick hiding in the
Box [__] really got
me I'm like it's going to be [__]
five of us getting and Nick not getting
it I be like huh you guys so me me
knowing that Nick has it makes me happy
yeah that's pretty
good even if the rest of us don't have
real ones if is real dude still walking
around like when people randomly see it
and uh or like friends or whatever that
see it don't know the story and they're
like yo that looks so cool yeah I know
somebody said that to me they're like yo
your tattoo looks hard and I'm like shut
the [__] up you don't know [__] about t
it's tough to just be like yeah you know
like playing all you also want to share
the most ridiculous and meaningful part
about it well because it's a 5- minute
story you got to do a five- minute story
every time you talk about at least 5
minutes just lie and say your grandpa's
half Chinese or whatever I started doing
that I say half Japanese and I'm like
that's it my grandpa's half Japanese oh
so you're Japanese I'm like yes
sir yes sir in and out that's how you
get in and out of the argument have you
guys had some favorite guests this year
what were some of your favorite guests I
love Colleen yeah she's the best I don't
even see her as a guest anymore yeah she
she not team Beau boy for probably my
least favorite regular who else what
else you guys
got dude the first time Jesus came here
yeah that sh was crazy I remember
[__] laughing till I was tearing up
Jesus is one of my favorites for sure I
didn't get to meet him yet really no
dude you would hate him he would steal
your thunder dude he's way funnier than
you it's cuz on Steve days like he
doesn't want anyone be
funny take a load out when Steve's here
we don't usually get guests anymore oh
that's true cuz when Steve's here it's
like this guest look he Santa he's got
so many different hats on Jason chenny
he's kind of fam now too dude the yeah
the feeling of when uh Bart's realtor
was here that was that was that was kind
of funny oh and I wasn't here right we
all we all set up bro we were all so
suspicious that this was a prank yeah we
thought we were we were getting that
would have been a really good prank and
then Joe wasn't here either right for
some reason yeah he wasn't here yeah so
how is that when we're gone like it's
fine does it work yeah it works but
barely it depends on the guest that
particular time we were like are they
going to pop out remember that time
Anthony was sick Bart and Joe were gone
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then we had
to do that little five table set up CU
we only had five people cuz last minute
he was sick yeah we didn't have no we
were like short one those videos were
awkward as [__] yeah it was it was hard
it was Walter it was Walter me him Ken
and and can and the angle made it so
weird like I was like we might as well
try something different so there's some
significance yeah or else just be like a
one guy over here yeah I know
yeah yeah that was a crazy one I liked
uh I remember some of the more
captivating stories was um remember when
Jeremy was on here oh yeah cuz he works
so closely with Keanu and just he great
so usually we try to like you know we
have like all kinds of like funny talks
and stuff but like just hearing him
share his stories of of like working
with 8711 like w That's crazy dude Dr
Mike and Jared was [__] awesome
they're funny cuz Dr Mike is [__] a
genius dude he's so funny dude he's like
the he's like Jewish guy with so many
Jewish jokes yeah I was going to say I
can't believe how sharp his mind is he's
Jewish he's so fast like even Jewish say
it again we time
Jewish spell it is he a
gentile yeah he's like that guy's so
funny he's not he's not even comedian by
like any could be he could be a stand up
yeah great dude was it this year that we
saw Ryan eat stinky tofu mhm at the
beginning of the year Adventures was it
yeah was that this year was that this
year I felt like that was last year what
about Airsoft that was pretty crazy that
was this year that was this year that
was this year that was tons of that felt
like last was like April right Dam that
was last year it feels like it I don't
knowof was this year for sure really I
remember it being cold me too so it must
have been like January February or
something I like all the the JK adventur
that we've done so far have been fun we
only been you want to host one what if
Jiu-Jitsu yeah shark shark tank Nick we
we film in Vegas and la and Hawaii yes
please yeah but we can't afford it so
then like you guys got to pay out of
pocket we'll try to make it happen well
me for you it would be easier so we
don't have to go you just drive down the
street money dude ah man why do it got
to always be about money man that's why
we came here dog yeah [__] why is it got
to be my money imagine talking to like a
new hire at Jun be like so how much you
why is it got to be about why can't you
just work 12 hour day yo do for the
passion for Love For Love bro love of
boba come on was it was it this year
that uh we [__] had that one moment
we started getting mad and me and Joe
started arguing with each other and we
had to take like 5 minutes outside what
were you guys arguing about yeah it was
like oh that's when you thought he
thought you were like I was you were
sitting next to me and then I was trying
to say something and then you you
thought I was mocking you you tried to
help out and I was trying to back you up
and you I think you were buzzed that
time too no but I was upset cuz y'all
Wasing on me super hard you didn't let
me finish speaking I was backing you up
and you're like I'm trying to stop you
from joking about me you keep [__]
joking about me definitely looked like
you about to junk on me extra hard it
sound like I'm trying to be on your side
and protect you I forgot what you were
saying but yeah you're [__] being
mean to me it's sound like you were you
were saying up for the greatest
punchline ever heard to man everybody
was giving me the look like like oh [__]
Joe's about to dunk H say something nice
because each of us dunked on Anthony and
then you were up so we're like oh here
it comes get the freaking Grand Slam and
then he started going and then Anthony's
like to ruin the whole thing one of the
greatest meltdowns I've ever seen and
you were like what the [__] why you got
to do
that he's doing right
here I don't think think it sounds like
we said that by the way so
far I'm just going to not it have to do
it but it sounded so funny because it's
like what you're yelling about is so
silly that it like makes it way funnier
but then we all took like 5 minutes
outside we all like walked outside just
to be like all right well I was like yo
we need a reset dude let's go outside
and just [__] get some air well cuz
also I think everyone was caught off
guard like why is Anthony
mad and then I'm mad at Anthony for
being mad and I was like why is he mad
at me for being mad I'm the one who's
mad because the one time that you were
like actually going to help him out
really sounded like it was going to be
awesome joke I didn't see it from that
point of view I was disappointed that
the punchline never
came so Steve had to say at the end I
was like sincerely trying to back up his
point or I forgot what it was but I was
trying to prove his point and then it
got interrupted and I got in trouble and
I started fighting him you [__]
well [__] you then
I just I'm just glad that's all all it
takes like we're just dudes we go
outside talk it out done we don't have
to like quit the podcast and [__] that's
dope we put hands in the middle said
yeah and then I deleted my YF JK video
right
after sched uploaded scheduled upload I
think that's the really cool part is
behind the scenes I wish people can see
I mean we already talk about things like
the massive pay cuts and the multiple
pay cuts I that we've done 40% slash and
then for Black Friday I fly slashed it
again I don't know how many more times I
can slash but you guys are still here
and then um pass to us we PID it come
it's not all about money you know what
we talk about $ 40% of $100 is not that
bad well 40% of $4 an hour is still a
pretty small slash but big for you guys
but um I think you move the show to
Bangladesh we'll have more purchasing
power we'll just have more purchasing
power I was already thinking about doing
uh standings for you guys from a third
old country like a Filipino call center
I I don't really mean it Indians are
funny too I either country you'll still
get a guy just like me yeah that's true
no matter what country you look like
young Santa right now hey tight I wish
yeah but I wish they can kind of see the
the actual like behind the scenes
sometimes it's boring but the moment is
actually is cool and how well we get
along and yeah it's pretty nice and we I
I wish we could figure out a way to
transfer that here so they can kind of
we're pretty [__]
transparent I think we I think once the
camera's cut we pretty much stay the
same
the same roast continue it's not like
back when I was here in 2015 and they
would cut cameras and none of you guys
would speak to each
other that's funny really 2015 I wasn't
hearing well no not was it 2015 I
remember there was a time when we were
filming like okay now we do about 20ish
articles mhm we used to do about 40 mhm
it was much quicker though the Articles
were less than 10 minutes and then not
only that we would probably film during
lunch we would film Vlogs and then we
would film yeah you guys were filmed out
for we would film something else at the
end of the day on the couch over there
and then at night we would go eat dinner
and talk for another two hours yeah you
guys when I came in we it was
2016 and we would do 36 videos and then
we would do no OTR didn't exist yet and
then it was just like yeah like you said
10-minute articles every the whole day
but it was such a blast like it was easy
when I came in we were doing films and
sketches and news wasn't here yet so I
must have been here before you yeah was
a long time ago but I seen you for I was
here every time hey was split the room
this year too yes yes it split the room
was good fans love to split the room
stuff yeah split the room when you don't
agree you were
here no but that's when he was like not
eating and getting buffed oh that's true
brain fog was he his [__] he was over
there we like ran on different side of
the table like split the room
you guys think we should do for
20 what do you guys think we should do
for like 20204 to like like he said
earlier guys trip is sounds okay okay
should we bring them along yeah or just
be like n no no no we should bring them
okay oh oh I think we should film and
document moments cuz then it's a tax R
yeah oh yeah it's a production expense
not not entertainment thank you totally
different tax bracket by the way that be
cool like a Blair Witch documentary
that'll be nice more Adventures I would
love to ghost hunt are we serious all
the things that I would love to do
that's probably number one Ghost Hunt JK
stays at like a haunted place that' be
so oh that'd be pretty cool it just
happened so I don't think said I'm down
n he says he's down but then he's going
to leave at the Crystal party like he's
going to leave at
7:30 I got to go like I said it just
happened so it's not like we've we've
all like [__] come from this and and
can totally wrap our minds around the
glory of it but the [__] redo that
Ryan is Big insane that's the cherry on
top
dude so we haven't all officially done a
meet and greet together as the careful
boys that's what we got to do you guys
want to do that all right we'll do that
they've been asking for that this is
something that I've been wanting to do
in JK history but for some reason we
have never been able to do well we did
the college tour which was cool I want
to do a tour yeah we should do it I want
to do like a j like a careful boy
whether it's a live show a live like
meet and greet or whatever it is I want
to figure out a way to do that let's do
it another one that I want to do is
create a show where all of our fans
dress up in business suits right and we
take over like a Convention Center in
Vegas and we all dress up like [__]
gurus Financial gurus with [__] head
we'll all have a different character we
do panels we'll do panels and we'll just
all have a convention and we're the only
ones in the not so it's almost like the
renaissance fair but we're like it's a
business Fair it's it how to sell your C
now people are going to laugh okay go
ahead and laugh I'll
wait this is a real business thing right
it's like [__] like that you got that
little wire here this just sounds like
it's going to cost a lot and not really
reap too much reward like our earlier
Vegas trip at the Trump Tower that was
just more for the boys you know I think
no the best business idea here is we're
going to get the convention hall for
like $10,000 we're going to charge the
fans like $5 entry fee and then we're
going to be very under by the end of the
show and then we're going to have to beg
our patreons to donate more money so we
can cover our debts but we'll sell JK
coloring books to cover
the we'll launch the throwback towels
will do pretty well though throwback
towels recovery backpacks I'll do that I
like that we'll call it the Recovery
Fund backpacks I like that you have so
much you probably have so much more
detail about the convention center thing
than just the meet and greet which is
probably way easier to plan and the fans
actually want that what if we s wall
vinyls of pictures of the background so
then the pants could make their their
background look as like this oh that'll
be cool so they can pretend that they're
in the chat with us he's going to do it
stop suggesting it do anything do
anything forer she'll do anything how do
I I'm just trying to keep the [__]
walls here standing up man you guys got
to help me help me sell some
[__] how can we buil our
audience F them for aprs and
apy